[music playing]
[speaking spanish]
I'm not going to lie, it's
always a rush getting access
to these clandestine worlds.
The cocaine pit,
the starting point
for such a storied black
market trade ranks up there.
But as the reporter
high wears off,
I realize that the whole process
boils down to brute labor
and simple chemistry.
[speaking spanish]
So they've been doing
this for three days,
and now this is the final step,
which they mix it with salt.
It takes 400 kilos,
almost 900 pounds, of coca
leaves to make one
kilo of cocaine.
They're soaked in water,
acid and bleach, which draws
the drugs out of the leaves.
And now it's ready to
be moved on to smaller
containers to the lab.
[speaking spanish]
[music playing]
Here in this
makeshift lab, they'll
start the purification process.
[speaking spanish]
Researchers discovered how
to extract cocaine from coca
leaves over 150 years ago, and
Americans got their first taste
of the drug in Coca-Cola
back in the 19th
century before it was banned by
the federal government in 1914.
It's a really,
really intense smell.
[speaking spanish]
To purify cocaine in the
middle of the Peruvian jungle,
they figured out how
to extract the drug
using simple household chemicals
and a whole lot of gasoline.
In this lab, each batch
requires 70 gallons.
[speaking spanish]
Ammonia, bleach,
cement, lime, gasoline.
With each toxic additive,
the drug becomes
more and more concentrated.
So what they're doing is that
they're removing the top of it,
which is the fuel,
and the bottom,
there's a clear
sort of liquid, and
that's where the drug remains.
Do you see it's pretty dark?
And that's all the gasoline, and
the clear part now underneath.
[speaking spanish]
So yeah, that's the
drugs right there.
So they call that clear
liquid, they call it the soup.
[speaking spanish]
[laughter]
They asked me if
I wanted to try it.
[laughter]
I said no.
[speaking spanish]
Oh, check this out.
This is amazing.
It's crazy to think that
only weeks from now,
this jungle soup will disappear
up some American's nostrils.
Now it's time for the final
step, a splash of ammonia
to solidify the drugs.
[speaking spanish]
OK, they have to speed it,
we have to speed it up, OK?
With so many livelihoods
depending on this lab,
Civichia's friend is taking
a massive risk giving
us a peek behind the curtain.
So when the chemist disappears
for a moment, I begin to worry.
[speaking spanish]
OK, guys, we have
to go right now.
[speaking spanish]
[tense music playing]
Let's go, let's go.
His crew was spotted by
somebody up on the road.
They say that we have to get
into the car get out of here.
OK.
We have to go fast.
No, no, no.
[speaking spanish]
Are they all inside?
[car engine]
[tense music playing]
Thankfully we escape
without incident,
but the drugs long journey
north is only just beginning.